hi everyone
um
so I'm going to talk about uh who about
data today who who who wrote SQL
yay okay because if you're not if you
don't write SQL my Talk's gonna go way
over your head
um
um and I'm gonna first I'm gonna talk
about
um some miscon first I'm going to talk
about why why I'm capable of talking
about this problem and then and then
we're going to talk about some
misconceptions you have about data that
that if you use SQL uh it'll be
something that you
probably think you know but anyway I
think it'll so what I'm talking about
the SQL stuff it will seem really simple
but pay attention so the first thing I'm
going to talk to do is tell a joke
okay when I was uh a kid my stepmother
was always mad at me for doing a sloppy
job about things and so this so she told
me this joke and um there's a a busker
who's playing violin
and um and uh he's he's playing concerto
and we're playing something and a little
Italian old man comes up next to him and
listens to him very intently and then
when he finishes the song the uh
uh the the Italian man goes Encore
Encore and so the guy plays it again
and then after he's done the little
timing goes encore encore
and so he does it one more time and when
he stops this time he says I I know
you're appreciating my music but why do
you keep saying encore and the little
the man says you're going to do it again
and again and again until you get it
right
[Laughter]
I've been building the same thing over
and over again
for a bazillion years okay uh I just got
asked how did you get to looker how did
you get to Malloy well in in 1987 I
wrote my first database programming
language called force it was the native
code compiler that you know and two of
us wrote it in Assembly Language for two
million lines of code and then I built
dbase and I was architect on dbase and I
built the first application server for
the web that was hooking up a web server
and a database in a programming language
and then I did a bunch of startups where
I built tooling I was the CTO of these
companies and the very first thing that
I would do when I would come in was that
I would build an interface to data so
that normal people in the company could
start looking at data so I built it at a
at a company that was one of the first
gig economy companies called liveops and
then I built it at a at an ad tech
company and then I built it at a
staffing company and then eventually I
said you know I'm going to start a
company because I keep doing the same
thing over and over again and we built
looker
okay and
um so we learned a lot building liquor
now when when one of the great things
about starting a company and being and
listening to your customers and building
something new is that people make you
smarter and so as we were building
looker I get to I would go sit with ttos
and they would tell me you know it would
be better if you did this and it would
be better if you did that and have you
thought about looking at it this way and
and we learned a lot while building
looker and so Malloy is the next
the next thing and so that's what I'm
going to talk about today which is this
language that we're building to deal
with data where we're taking all the
stuff that we learned over the years and
trying to build something new and it's
so it's it's experimental it's still a
work in progress but I think you'll
you'll be excited to see it
and
the first thing that we realized while
building actually we can Building look
where we discovered this but data is not
rectangular
right when you dealing with data that's
at all complex it's not in a table
right humans
humans think in rectangles if you're
looking if you're using Excel if you're
using um SQL you know the the operations
that you do
on on data is always against a rectangle
um so whether it's you start by
filtering that you have a rectangle you
filter the rows the standard thing that
you do is you Group by something and you
aggregate you
um you can project which is you can take
a table and you can add another column
which is basically excel's way of doing
things
um or window functions which are kind of
like a mix between the two of those
things right but those are the
operations that we do against rectangles
and in SQL what we do is we do a join
which we take a table we bunch of tables
We join them together and then we do
these operations
right and
um and that changes how we think about
data that is that is the fundamental way
that we operate on data this is why the
way we build data warehouses is because
of this in in this form and what I'm
saying is it's a misconception
which is really a weird thing to say
right and I'm going to show you why
that's a misconception
um so we I'm gonna a simple orders table
we
we have four orders made by uh
what three different users right on a
couple of different days really simple
data set
and they bought each of them bought some
different things they bought candy
because that's what I like candy so so
uh user one uh user one bot uh uh
chocolate and what's where are we uh I'm
sorry the the
first order contained uh uh chocolate
and Twizzlers and what we end up doing
here is uh we want to compute the two
things from this so we want to compute
uh the total amount of Revenue and we
want to figure out the total shipping
cost these are the two things we want to
compute
right and so how would we go about doing
this well the compute shipping is pretty
simple you just take the table add a sum
on it right no problem right and to
compute the revenue it's pretty simple
we just sum this column right that's how
we would do it
um
and and if we want to do it by date we
can add a dimension in it and we can
look at the the shipping by date or we
can look at the
um
uh the revenue by date it's again
relatively simple computation
but
um
but then you want to ask the question
how does shipping relate to revenue so
you want a table that looks like this
and you would think that you could do
this right how many people have used
this as an interview question
right right this is a you know what's
wrong with this query
the wrong what's wrong with the query is
that the shipping is wrong because it's
overstated
and why is the shipping overstated
because uh for order one there are two
items and so we double count shipping
for item one
and for order uh two we double count
shipping for item two and for order four
we double count the shipping right
so so we have to do a different
technique in order if we're using SQL to
do this right or generally this is the
generally generally what you end up
doing is something different than this
and what you do is you combine
rectangles you produce a rectangle that
looks like this
and then you produce another rectangle
that looks like that
and then
you combine them together with a query
that looks like this so this is kind of
how you would write this query right
anybody would write it differently than
that
pretty much pretty much what you would
do with it right
um
and this is kind of how we work with
data but it does it have to be this way
um
uh if we want to take
order date and we want to look at it by
user instead
we have to take this query
right and we have to go through and
replace every place that we have ordered
date with user ID
right and we get our results and so
there's a lot of so when you have SQL
you end up copying pasting a lot you end
up you end up you end up building up
these queries with with templates right
there's a lot of ways of trying to solve
this problem but mostly but mostly it's
the problem is that we can't operate on
the rec we can't we're operating on a
rectangle when the graph's in a network
is that making sense
so this is the basis of traditional data
warehousing this is why when we do ETL
we have so many fact tables right
because we produce our unit of
reusability is a a table that looks like
some dimensionality and some calculation
and you produce a whole bunch of these
things and then you kind of join them
together in in a way that makes sense to
you so you're always whatever you're
always producing the your your
reusability is actually data not not
definition your reasonability is not the
the calculation for for total um
shipping but the fact table that is that
thing that you join together
and so um so this is kind of the whole
Inman thing the whole the whole
traditional data warehousing way of
doing things
um but it was designed at a time when
databases were slow
um
and and and and it has another problem
which is that if you're going to produce
an intermediate artifact it's not real
time
right so you're going to produce this
thing and then join it up again later
so
Malloy enter Malloy Malloy solves this
problem how does so how does Malloy
solve this problem right this is the old
VC pitch you set up a problem and then
you show a solution so now I'm going to
show you the solution and
um
Malloy makes the problem promise that
joint relations don't affect
calculations
so if you define a calculation against a
rectangle and another decoration gets
another rectangle and you do the
computation about them in the same query
they won't affect each other no matter
how the join pattern works
how does that
so you first describe so join patterns
are really important you first describe
the network because that's all the data
that you might want to talk about and
the second thing that you do is you
write the query against it but when you
write that query it guarantees
computational correctness relative to
try to the rectangle that you're dealing
with
um and we call that Network a source so
you're going to hear me talk about data
sources and a source is basically a
network of of tables that are joined and
some also some calculations that are
associated with it
um
and so the the locality of the
computation is the locality of the
rectangle that you're that you're
dealing with so
let's take a look at a simple Malloy
query so the first part of this is the
source and this and and Malloy queries
are actually much simpler than this but
I'm gonna but I'm writing one without
basically the the most literal query I
can write that's equivalent to SQL I'm
taking two tables one orders
and Order items and I'm joining them
together on order ID
right
um
the second thing I'm doing is I'm doing
a calculation for total revenue now I
notice that I have to say items that
price that some because
the the calculation for this sum is
relative to the items table so so I have
to know which where I'm doing the
calculation in the network so items dot
price tells me where and then the sum
operator operates on that on that number
and because I'm summing that number I
know where in the network to operate on
it
and then total shipping
um that son and the result
is my answer
right
um so that just makes things a lot
easier especially if I just want to look
at different dimensionalities so I
always talk about exploring data as kind
of like x-ray right you come out at one
angle or a CT scan you come in from one
angle you come at it from another angle
and so the ability to have the ability
to move and try different you know you
can pick any dimension in the network in
this whole network and you can change it
and this query is going to work and give
you accurate results
and so that gives you this freedom to
think to not have to think about the
problem reformulate your queries it
really simplifies the way that you work
with data
so this is so we call it dimensional
freedom
does that make sense
so this is what that query looks like
um you could write it
um it's kind of
basically what it does is it Aggregates
the thing that's repeated based on a
distinct key you don't have to
understand this okay but but if you want
to understand it what it does is it
collects uh it figures out a primary key
for the thing that's repeated and then
dedupes it and then does the sum against
that for you
um
so malloy's reusability is the source so
in that query that I just did I can
actually write a source that looks like
this
and what this is doing is it's saying
here's the network of joins here are the
calculations I might want to make in
this network right and then querying
becomes
really simple
right because I just have that Source
it's all predefined and I can actually
write these queries that just do the
right thing and so what you end up doing
is you write this so we talk about
reusability you write the source once
and then all you have lots of little
queries
that do different things that are all
very readable
does that make sense
pause for any questions
I'm moving fast so I have time
yeah nope
great
um
it also turns out that data comes
naturally nested so parquet format or
Json or you know or you know or or
spanner or all of this these data tables
have data that is naturally nested okay
so normally in SQL you have all the all
the tables are separate and then you
join them but in the real world
you have things like Json objects and if
I were looking at an order stable there
exists no order items without an order
right you can't really have an order
item that's not part of an order so in
this case we might have a Json table
that expressed the the orders just like
we were seeing it right so you have an
order and then you have an array of
items that is nested within that is
nested within the order right that's
just the way it is you don't really you
really wouldn't having to separate them
is kind of an artifact of the SQL engine
not really of the real world right
because it's it's kind of the way you
would want it and Malloy
knows how to deal with this
automatically so if you load a parquet
file
with nested data
then only knows how to deal with it and
can just do the thing automatically for
you
Isn't that cool
I think that's cool
yeah yeah right so it's really cool
because you can just take something
that's a protobuf like an output of or
you know basically the output of your
logs and you can just start querying
them directly with Malloy right just
straight out of the box
yeah so it joins the Malloy are there
I'm sorry the question was what's what's
the deal with Join one and join many
what do you what's that okay so joints
are pretty simplified and Malloy there
are three types of joints there's a
cross joint a joint cross I joined many
and I Join one and a joint one says I am
an order item and I have one order or
I'm a order and I have one user and if
I'm in um orders I have many items so
join many would be I I have one order
has many items so you have to indicate
which that is so that the calculations
kind of can work correctly but but
that's the thing that it's the only
thing that you needed to find to make
sure the calculations are correct
um
so we talked about how Molloy reads
nested data but Malloy also writes this
to data so in every dialect of SQL
that's kind of mature there is uh there
are arrays and there are structs and
there are
a array Ag and you know and all of those
things are really because our weird are
are really just nested queries
okay and so and and so this works by
doing an array AG but what it does is it
allows any query that you have in Malloy
that is a top level query can be nested
so that by items query is of legitimate
query that could be at the top level or
at any level and you can Nest any query
within any other query in Malloy to
produce nested results
and so what we're seeing here is that we
have our order items our order date and
we have our Revenue by date and then we
see the items that we sold on that date
right and that's a real pretty readable
query too so that's nesting and we're
going to see more of that and so Malloy
operate Malloy
reads non-rectangular data and it writes
non-rectangular data
and this is what that query would look
like if you had to write it yourself
okay so
um but it's nice because it just it
abstracts it away it makes it very
simple it makes a very simple usage but
but it but it writes queries that you
wouldn't necessarily want to try to
write yourself
question
that was advice
what format would it write that nested
table into would it write it into a Json
object all all the SQL dialects return
nested data in arrays so it'll be an
array of structs that it would return
and if you've got that out as Json from
your database it would come back out as
Json so it it returned so what this is
doing is it's producing it's doing an
array AG of a struct for you and
returning the results
hi
he's asking how efficient it is it uh
basically what my concern is that you
might be throwing too many sub queries
uh to generate the result and the format
that you want and yeah because actually
these queries are super efficient they
read the data exactly one time
okay so uh the the first part of the
query produces a wide table and then
it's
is essentially the way that this
operates is the first part of the query
produces a wide result and then it and
then it nests the data for you so all
Malloy queries read basically read data
only one time
and and you always translate to SQL
right oh it's every every single Malloy
queries translates to one sequel
excuse me
so the data loads in a memory system
memory or uh how where it's stored so
Malloy writes to bigquery right we'll
write queries against bigquery duckdb
and postgres today
and Malloy does not store any results so
Beloit always you you have a Malloy
model you write the model it reads this
it it first reads the schema from the
database for the tables that it's
interested in it figures out how to
write a query and it presents that query
back to the database and Returns the
results
so it it does it's it's always it's all
entirely SQL based SQL is Assembly
Language for Malloy so you can think of
it as the sequel as the C plus compiler
for C or you know C converts to assembly
Malloy converts to SQL
okay so uh
okay I'm gonna pause on the questions
for a second because I'm gonna go
through a demo and then I think we'll
answer so uh if you open your laptop
go to that URL
and you're running Malloy
and then I will run Malloy too
so it's github.dev Malloy data slash
patterns
and this is going to be Malloy running
in your web browser
so here we are
um in GitHub uh I don't know if you've
used if you know that vs code runs in
GitHub in a weird way but if you go to
it if you go to any repo and you're
logged in to GitHub
um I have data that's here I have uh
some data some parquet files that I put
up here
um I have
um and I have some alloy files if I
press dot here what this does is it
loads
um it it basically loads vs code
and then what it does what it should ask
you if it doesn't it should ask you to
install install Malloy if you don't see
that type Malloy and install this
extension
okay and once we once you've installed
it you you can now run Malloy in your
browser and it run it uses Dr B wasm
that is built into your that is built in
so this is all running in this processor
this isn't even my machine I walked in
logged into GitHub and I'm running this
because my machine wouldn't talk to the
screen so that may other be problems but
we'll see that let's hopefully the demo
gods are good to me today
um I can once once I've done that I can
go over and so here's a simple Malloy
file and I can run a query
by just clicking this run thing and it
will run it for me so here's a simple
one airport stable I've added a couple
of measures airport count average
elevation percent of all and I've done a
nested query like we looked at earlier
right so but I'm going to show you we'll
start with something more interesting
so this is Beloit also runs in notebooks
so I have a notebook here it's uh I'm
gonna I'm gonna run it show you the
kinds of results that you can generate
and then we're gonna go build it we're
gonna actually turn around and build it
by hand and so you can see how it all
works so first so here is the here is
this there's a
um we're looking at airline flights this
is the data set that I used when I was
actually starting looker I'm still using
the same data set since 2000 whatever
um and uh what I'm looking at here is
flights by carrier and I want to know
for each destination uh the number of
flights and then the carriers that fly
to that destination and all kinds of
information about it so we'll we'll get
to this in a second but let's take a
look at the results so here is uh
Atlanta there are 17 000 flights Delta's
the big one that flies here look at you
can see it over the years we can take a
look at Delta and see where Delta flies
it looks like six percent of them go to
St Louis and
uh and uh five percent go to Huntsville
and Atlantic Southwest flies a lot of
flights and then there's a lot of
smaller flights smaller airlines that
fly
and this is repeated right for every
Airline for every airport so we can go
look at Dallas Fort Worth and we can see
that that had 17 000 flights and
American American Eagle are the big ones
and this is where American flies to
Chicago into Washington and and
and so on
and we can then look at Chicago and
and this is all out of this one data
model
one model
and one query
right
we can
um here's another query which basically
tracks a plane plane through the sky so
we're looking at Southwest Airlines for
the first five days of 2002 and we want
to look at all of their planes and see
what the routes were for all of the
planes so we're going to filter the data
first and then we're going to group by
tail number which is the plane and then
we're going to look at it by day and
then within each date we're going to
look at the the flight routes
and so this airport this aircraft on
this day started in Tampa and went to
Austin
and then Austin to LAX in LAX to Oakland
and Oakland to Burbank Etc and then the
next morning from Oakland it went to uh
to Burbank and to Burbank to
and so we can see this plane flying
through the sky and then another plane
of Southwest and another plane of
Southwest
okay and these are each of these we just
ran two queries one query for the first
one and one query for the second one
um okay that look cool
yeah that's cool right
all right how does this work
let's start with a really simple model
we'll go to test that Malloy notebook
so I have a so I have I have some some
data tables
um and in in Malloy I have a Malloy
schema that I can click and it shows me
the structure for each of these tables
so here's the here's the fields that are
in flights here are the fields that are
in carriers I can preview the flights
table by clicking preview and it will
show me that right
um and I can add a cell to write a query
against this so I'm going to notebook so
I'm going to make a new query and I'm
going to write query
flights
aggregate
byte count
is count all right cool how many flights
are in this database all right there are
a third of a million flights
um
the very first thing I can do is I can
build we talk about sources being
reusable I can take this
and I can build a reusable measure here
ah if I could type
sorry it's not my laptop
uh flight count is that
all right and then I don't have to say
this anymore
and let's group this by carrier into
Group by
carrier
okay and because we saw that in flights
there was a carrier
here so we can Group by it and then I
can run this
and great
that's pretty terrific right
um
well I really want the carrier's name so
I can make a join
let's take a look at the carriers table
again
uh preview the carriers table
it looks like code is the thing that we
would want to join on
so we can join
join
one carriers
on
carrier equals carriers to code
great
and then if I go into here actually go
back to here we notice that the carriers
showed up I can I can look at the
nickname I can just grab that and we can
replace that with carrier's nickname and
then when we run it we have our
Southwest cool right so you're starting
to build up this reusable model the
query is more readable the things that
I'm doing are more useful you know
I can uh
let's take this
we can actually put queries themselves
into the model
query
by carrier
is
and let me indent this
all right and I can take this as
by carrier
and let's for grins let's add another
measure here which is total distance
total or actually average distance
and let's add that here
great all right so now when I run this
by carrier
I can see
that like I've got my average distance
in
pretty simple this this query gets to be
reused what's really nice about this is
if you're going from an API all of your
query stuff can actually be in the model
in the code there's an npm library for
this you can use to like there's
so what's what's great is that all of
the logic stays within stays within the
Malloy model
um
the other cool thing we can do here is
we saw graphs before and graphs are just
a kind of a rendering option so I can
style this
and if I run this again
it shows up as a bar chart
pretty cool right pretty relatively
simple straightforward easy to use like
you know not
um let's let's build another query
let's let's look at it by
month
so time is something we always wanted
there's is in there like every it's one
of the things you do all the time so we
Group by
uh departure month
is departure time
dot month
and aggregate
a little aggressive there month
and we'll aggregate
flight count
okay run that this is probably great as
a line chart
so we can do a style
and we can run that
perfect let's take this one and put it
in our
all right so we can then add another
query query
by month
is and we paste that indent it
and there's another cool trick I can do
here which is that if I actually name
this thing with AN underbore line chart
I don't have to do the style thing
and if it's nested in something it'll
just do the right thing so I can do this
by month line chart
and if I run that it's great it it does
the right thing okay so let's build one
more query
and I'm gonna
um Group by destination
which is what we were looking at before
and we're going to aggregate flight
count
and then we're going to Nest some things
we're going to Nest by carrier and we're
going to nest
by month line chart
look at that
is that
see see
and this is all where you can you could
run this all in your browser like
they're all examples here now I can go
in and I I can Nest I can have net
things with nested and Nest further
things
um if we go into patterns uh you can see
that the quick start for Malloy is all
here and can you can run any of these
queries and learn the language and this
patterns thing it's so every one of
these queries is just runnable you can
just click it and run
um there are data pipelines I love this
this is one of my favorites okay who's
ever tried to build a histogram in SQL
right and what is the problem is that
the endpoints are always a drag right
it's like you wanna you've got a pin
you've got to bend it by something but
that bin size really depends on your
data right it's always you're always
trying to figure out how to bin it on
the data so so this query this simple
little query basically by elevation bins
it figures out the Min and Max and then
collects the data right and then the
next this is a pipeline statement this
says take the output of the last query
and pipe it so the first stage of the
query does this
if we run this
the first stage of the query produces
the bin size and then a bunch of data
and the second stage of the query
produces
produces bins 30 bins well let's make it
10 bins
and run it and we'll see okay now it now
it oh that's wrong hang on
now it's 10 bins right you can so this
this little data model basically makes
it so that the data auto bins so I'm
going to put it back to 30 here
and and when we run something we can
look at like this query
um is the overall distribution but this
is the distribution in Florida right and
you'll notice that it shows you a
histogram that makes sense for Florida
right because it figured out the bin
size and produced 30 bins and then
within each of the states it produces
the bin that's appropriate as a nested
query for each of these things because
these because once you've built this
query that's into the source it can be
used anywhere
right and you if we if we want to run
this query you don't want to write the
SQL you don't
but you do want the result
okay that's pretty much where I'm gonna
so make sure some lawyer makes things
reusable it it's it's that we're um
we're in the process of adding our hope
our goal is that Malloy is turning
complete for data everything that you
can do in SQL you can do in Malloy you
can currently if we don't do it you can
escape the sequel to
um to run parts of the language in SQL
so if you need to do a union we don't do
you need that you can do that in SQL for
example
um uh window functions are coming in the
next month and
um
and uh there there are some percent of
uh percent of total calculations that
Malloy does that nothing else really
does very well and all kinds of really
cool goodies that are in the language so
that's that's it
[Music]